JOSE ESPARZA: So my
name is Jose Esparza.
I'm a junior in
mathematics and economics.
My focus is
development economics,
so I got to know Michel's--
Professor DeGraff's
work, because
of what he does with the
MIT Haiti initiative.
And the reason I
took this course
is because I thought that his
efforts were very important,
and that it was an opportunity
to improve the world
and I wanted to hear
more of what he did,
and the theory of why
he does what he does.
After taking this
course, my perspective
of language and
identity changed,
in that now I was able
to see the connection
between the languages we
speak, but also how that
ties into cultures, in
general, and more importantly
to politics.
And in some sense, we can see
a lot of the big things that
happen in society, like
neocolonialism, or the effects
of institutions-- a
lot of these things,
although they might be
cloudy in some sort,
language is a good
way to view the world.
One of the first
essays was to look
our own life, or a biography
through the lens of language.
And in studying how institutions
interact with each other
through the sense of
language opens up either
how some cultures are
not taken as seriously
as others, how it tells
you about the history
about the world.
And it taught me to see
language as something
that ties a lot of things
about humans together.
And it was just a different
way to look at the world.